the world's oldest commissioned warship
still in active service is birthed in
boston's historic navy yard we're
talking about the uss constitution whose
maiden voyage was 225 years ago and now
it is making even more history commander
billy farrell became the first woman to
take charge of that storage ship just
last week and our nancy chan went on
board to meet her
launched in 1797 the uss constitution's
history is american history it is an
honor to introduce commander b.j farrell
and now a new order reigns with
commander billy farrell at the ship's
helm the first woman to serve as its
captain there's only 76 other people in
history that have commanded this ship so
and now you're going to be the 77th
correct so it's an amazing feeling a
full circle journey for the 39 year old
naval academy graduate who was just a
teenager when she first visited the ship
what would you tell that young woman
today i think even if i told her that
one day she would be commanding the ship
she wouldn't believe me
farrell was second in command of a
guided missile cruiser before her new
assignment aboard the constitution
undefeated in battle the ship was
nicknamed old ironsides during the war
of 1812 when british cannonballs seemed
to bounce off its wooden hole a storied
history that included only men in
command until now with farrell relieving
commander john benda i know from the
past month turning the ship over
and the crew over
i could not be doing it to a better
naval officer the ship is in great hands
the constitution still sails at least
once a year a third of its active duty
crew women docked in boston it hosts
more than half a million visitors
annually it's such a special opportunity
not just for the ship but the navy as a
whole especially having all the public
here they get to see that there's a
female leading us i think that's really
special for everybody to see the
command's significance not lost on feral
as she takes lead of operations and
preserves the ship's legacy by telling
visitors of its rich naval history the
ship was ordered to be built under
president george washington commissioned
under president john adams very rarely
do we get to actually set foot on those
pieces of history that were you know
tied to those names it's usually only in
a book and so to be able to be that
representative and show the evolution of
you know where we started to where we
are and even where we're going is really
amazing farrell also a mother hopes to
inspire the next generation of sailors i
just want them to take this all in as
well and be able to finally look back
and say my mom was the captain of uss
constitution you know i've always almost
always been the senior female at my
command wherever that was i'm grateful
to have the opportunity to again show
those young female sailors that are in
the navy that if you put your mind to it
and work hard and if you want to command
a ship one day that it's possible and
that you can do it
taking the helm and commanding a new
course in history for cbs mornings i'm
mitzi chin in boston
[Music]